[Music]
foreign
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight on Piers Morgan uncensored a
year on from Vladimir Putin's deadly
invasion of Ukraine I'll talk
exclusively to former British prime
minister Gordon Brown on how to end this
war
that's another world exclusive is one of
the internet's biggest stars with more
fans than most a-listers and a bank
balance to match but is he a real boxer
Jake Paul controversially fights Tommy
Fury in Saudi Arabia this weekend but
first he gets in the ring with me
live from New York
well good evening welcome from New York
City where we're live and uncensored one
year ago Kiev Ukraine was a Cosmopolitan
European Capital the subway teamed with
people heading home after work cafes hum
to the sound of friends laughing music
belted out from bars packed with
revelers it was like any other European
city but at 4am the next morning
everything changed
foreign
[Music]
Russian missiles rained down on
presidential buildings Russian troops
poured across the border in a
three-pronged sold them as peaceful
democracy a formidable 40-mile column of
Russia machinery and troops headed for
the capital Putin's illegal war was
supposed to be over in three days
president zielinski was supposed to
surrender in hours but he didn't instead
he did this
president the president is here we are
all here our troops are here citizens
are here all of us are here protecting
the independent of our country and it
will continue to be this way glory to
our Defenders glory to Heroes glory to
Ukraine an astounding moment of courage
and of resistance well that moment also
Changed History zelenski told the West I
need ammunition not a ride and the whole
country followed his lead ukrainians
took up arms they battered back the
Russians facing down tanks in tractors
repelling the Invaders of the show of
force and bravery it's become the stuff
now of Legend now supposedly unbeatable
Russian column got stuck in the mud a
ran out of fuel Putin's image as an
infallible Iron Fist has disintegrated
we shouldn't sugarcoat this it's no
fairy tale Untold numbers of innocent
ukrainians have been slaughtered many of
those people who were traveling home
from work and having coffee with their
friends a year ago are now dead
maternity hospitals have been
incinerated women and children have been
murdered towns like Buca are now scarred
by war crimes massacres which will haunt
the country forever but Ukraine remains
Ukraine it remains also a free country
Russia's been hit by a package of
economic sanctions and Military Support
from the West that's unparalleled in
modern history Vladimir Putin thought
we'd all crumble but it didn't Ukraine
didn't and the West resolve hasn't
key stands proud it stands tall and most
important it stands free the Democracy
of the world have grown stronger
not weaker
but the autocrats of the world have
grown weaker not stronger our support
you for Ukraine will not waver NATO will
not be divided and we will not Tire
democracies of the world will stand
guard over Freedom today tomorrow and
forever
well for once Biden was right the brave
ukrainians holding off Russia's barbaric
Invaders are not just fighting for
Ukraine they're fighting for a free
world in which free people choose who
they want to lead them and their country
they're fighting for a world in which
borders matter and tyrants can't just
bully and bomb with impunity and grab
what land they want this war must end
soon because of every passing Day More
innocent ukrainians die but it must end
on Ukraine terms not Vladimir Putin's
and the West must give zelenski whatever
he needs to finish the job the freedom
of Ukraine depends on it but so does the
freedom and democracy of Western values
well former British prime minister
Gordon Brown is also in America at the
moment he's giving a speech in Texas on
the Ukraine war I spoke to exclusively
just before we came on air
good these are very serious times we're
facing the first anniversary tomorrow of
the Ukraine war of Putin's barbaric
invasion of Ukraine what is your reading
of where we are in the war first of all
right I think we've got a first of all
salute the courage of the Ukrainian
people lives buildings have all been
destroyed but the spirit of the
Ukrainian people has been indestructible
Hearts have been broken but I think
their courage has been unbreakable so I
think the first thing we've got to say
is that unexpected perhaps a year ago is
the sheer resilience and the willingness
to fight back as we've seen with
president zielinski but all the
Ukrainian people and the second thing I
think is clear is that the unity of the
West has been maintained so America and
Europe and NATO adding Sweden and
Finland have been working together NATO
Unity of course there's big issues about
fighter jets and big issues about tanks
but the unity has held I I think the
world thing is that the rest of the
world has not woken up to the
seriousness of the aggression that has
been practiced by Putin we've got to
persuade the rest of the world that this
is a turning point if we do not support
the Ukrainian people against uh the
Putin assault then people will think
that they can practice aggression with
impunity and that's why I'm wanting
Putin to be brought to Justice that's
why I favor a special tribunal that's
why the ICC the international criminal
court will not be able to do the job
because it cannot try the crime of
aggression against Ukraine but we can
all get together like at Nuremberg and
have a special tribunal where Putin and
his cabal would be brought to trial
we're both in America you're in Texas
I'm in New York a lot of that decision
making will depend on America's support
do you think that President Biden will
go along with what you would like to do
well I think it's been remarkable that
President Biden has visited Ukraine this
week and I think he should be
congratulated I know you did in your
columns and in your television
interviews say that this was a very
special uh thing that Biden did a year
on and I think it's important that he
sent that message both to the Ukrainian
people and to the rest of Europe that he
was 100 behind uh president zielinski
and what he was trying trying to do but
you know the whole of Europe the
European Parliament the European Union
the Europe Council of Europe the Nordic
countries the Baltic countries France
perhaps reluctantly to start Germany
perhaps reluctant to start now the
United Kingdom they've all said a
special tribunal should be set up the
exception is still America you cannot
allow the crime of aggression in the
modern world to go with impunity you
cannot send out a message at that
there's a safe haven for those who
practice this you cannot allow there to
be a hiding place for criminals like
Putin and whatever is to happen in the
future it is absolutely clear that you
can prove that the crime of aggression
was initiated in practice continues to
be practiced and of course the innocent
civilians rape mutilation all the
torture that has been carried out by
Russian soldiers that arises from the
foundational crime the crime of
aggression the one that was brought for
the Nazi war criminals in in 1946 and
the one that is relevant as a crime to
be prosecuted today so America I hope
will come along with Europe Europe has
gone with America on so many issues
America I think and President Biden
should use Friday should use the day to
say look this is the time when we'll add
the
judicial action to every everything else
that we're doing you had an
extraordinary first encounter with
Vladimir Putin at the Kremlin when you
were the chancellor of the executive in
the UK government 2006 and it was quite
chilling actually when you recounted
what happened there because he made you
sit in a smaller chair so that you had
to look up at him and then he started
reading you out all this information
about yourself
almost in a way to say I know about you
I know where you live buddy kind of
stuff
yeah yeah it was the old KGB agent and
as you know Putin is a small man he sits
at a desk above you you're in a city and
you're sort of sinking into that City so
you've got no choice but to look up at
him and he's issuing threats you know
we're going to sell our oil to to the
East and not to the West uh gas will
never come to Europe if you don't do
what we say and of course later if you
have an expansion of NATO there's going
to be retaliation what I understood
immediately you know some people thought
you could do business with Putin I never
thought that what I understood
immediately was that this guy all he
understands is strength he'll exploit
any weakness totally opportunist in
doing so and you've got to send out a
message of strength and it's got to be
United in the way that you convey that
message and we had to deal with lip
venenko's assassination as you know on
the Streets of London we knew that Putin
we knew Putin was planning further
assassinations we had to send a very
strong message that we would retaliate
and we would not allow this to happen we
gave 24-hour protection to lots of
citizens that we knew were being
targeted for assassination he was going
to send other Killers into the country
and it was only 10 years later I think
when the guard had dropped we had been
protecting people the guard had dropped
that we saw the Salisbury killings there
taking place uh I I mean no doubt that
you cannot trust Putin he is not a man
of his word that he only understands
strength and it's strength that we've
got to show now his strength we've got
to show by unity you know he's making
deals with other countries to sell his
oil 50 of his oils now going to China
and to and to India you know that also
he is uh there's a naval exercise at the
moment in South Africa South African Air
Forces Chinese forces and Russian forces
the way that he is trying to build Iran
they're trying to build Syria trying to
build support with other countries is
something that we've got a we've got to
counter one of your successes as prime
minister Boris Johnson as today come out
and said to Rishi sunak the current
prime minister that he must send fighter
jets to support Ukraine militarily and
also says China should be warned that it
would be an historic mistake if they
were to get involved directly on the
side of Vladimir Putin and Russia what's
your reaction to both of those things
well the worrying thing today is if the
American intelligence is correct and
China is considering giving physical
support to the to the Russian attack on
Ukraine now I don't know whether that
intelligence is has been proven to be
accurate and I don't know what the
Chinese plans are but clearly the
strongest possible message should be
sent I said a year ago that we were
bound to see a long War I'm afraid a
long war that we will see the decoupling
of Europe from Russia and that's
actually happening but the variable was
what China was going to do it was bound
to say it wasn't going to
really sort of criticize this so Soviet
Union on or the Russia but it hasn't
been giving physical support so that's a
very serious development and we've got
to look at what's happening there now
when you look at the military support uh
President Biden as you know is drawing a
fine line and trying to get a fine
balance between support for Ukraine and
active engagement in a war he's trying
to get a balance between delivering uh
if you're like military and other
support and a declaration of war and I
understand from my own experience in
government that this is a fine line a
very difficult thing to do I don't think
there should be a red line about sending
fighter jets I think that's worthy of
consideration and should be considered
and I know Netherlands Poland France uh
I said that they're supportive of this
but we do know from Ben Wallace the
defense secretary of the UK that this
will take a time uh and and therefore
it's not a silver bullet it's not a
Magic Bullet we've got to look at how we
can increase the support for Grant to
air surveillance ground to air action to
to get rid of Russian Jets from from
from the air and obviously we've got to
get the tanks to people as quickly as
possible this is essentially I think
everybody agrees a ground war at the
moment and the most we can do at the
moment I think quickly is to get the
tanks that we promise to to Ukraine uh
to them as soon as soon as possible does
this end with Ukraine being compelled to
seed one inch of territory lost
to Russia Ukraine rightly is United
around the Integrity of Ukraine
Putin believes that Ukraine is part of
Russia these are two irreconcilable
positions we have got to weaken Putin
now there are many reasons why Putin is
a lot weaker now than he was a year ago
he thought that NATO would not be United
he didn't think that Finland and Sweden
would come along he didn't think the
sanctions would be effective he thought
we would treat them like previous
governments had treated the invasion of
the Crimea he is not able to sell his
oil and gas in the way he has in the
future but he's still got reserves
Russia the Russian economy has not
collapsed and it's uh possibly going to
be growing faster than the United
Kingdom this year so he has managed to
survive some of the sanctions so far but
he is severely weakened the key thing
and this is why I'm supporting this
judicial action to bring him to trial in
The Hague and to say he is a war
criminal guilty of the crime of
aggression the key is to persuade the
whole of the world that this is a crime
time that is completely unacceptable in
the modern world it is possible to
imagine in his absence Putin being tried
in a few weeks time for the crime of
aggression it's adding to our Weaponry
if you like the military and the
material and the moral support at the
judicial weapon that was something that
has been used since Nuremberg to punish
war criminals Gordon Brown great to have
you making your debut on Piers Morgan
uncensored please come back soon really
enjoyed the conversation thank you
thank you peers
well next tonight some more sad news for
the gruesome twosome Harry and Megan's
popularity has plunged in a new poll
we'll talk about that next
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember it thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Felts is
on talk TV every night of the week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no with the people's Channel nobody else
uh every little helps for God's sake is
nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy
speechwriters here but we do and I
promise you discuss the issues that
matter to you yes I'm back talk TV not
with Morgan just before him Monday to
Thursday at 7pm join me just do it what
that one too
[Music]
thank you
well welcome back to Pittsburgh live
from New York uh in a few minutes we'll
be talking to Jake Paul who's got his
huge fight on Sunday night in Saudi
Arabia against Tommy Fury but for now
I'm joined by an All-Star panel it
doesn't get any bigger than this frankly
of Fox news channels comedian captain
and former wrestler tires well welcome
to both of you bringing your own yeah
correction not former I'm the current
reigning NWA World Heavyweight Champion
I apologize it's okay one assist penguin
to another
how are you both oh phenomenal living
the dream absolutely everybody it is a
dream
what is the dream just keep killing him
in the ratings keep winning at a high
level and having fun while you're doing
it absolutely I like that dream
um let's talk with Ukraine because
I've been in America a couple of weeks
now interesting sentiment here where
there are a lot of people who go along
with what Biden's been saying from
Ukraine which is we've got to help
Ukraine win this it's about freedom and
democracy for the world but a rising
number as often happens as a war goes on
and on of Skeptics saying well how is
this in America's interest how long does
America keep having to prop up this
Ukrainian resistance what do you think
well I think the biggest problem is
because we're we're not we're having
issues at home that's not getting
attention from the federal government
and I think that's the biggest thing is
we're seeing these huge checks going to
Ukraine and then eventually finding out
all these loopholes and all these monies
being filtered otherwise Meanwhile we're
having what's going on in Palestine Ohio
we're having issues with crime in our
country and we don't seem to be getting
any help from the federal government so
a lot of it is we're not taking care of
home but you're making uh appearances in
Ukraine but you couldn't show up in Ohio
so that's where the argument is does it
have to be either or I mean it's the
problem that they just haven't taken
seriously issues like the border issues
like this train derailment in Ohio that
actually if they had taken those
seriously then it's perfectly acceptable
and correct but the President should be
supporting Ukraine and being Keith is it
the problem is that not doing this
therefore that is more glaring to many
Americans I think what's glaring to me
is that if you raise any questions about
even the question that you just asked
even asking that can make oh you're a
puppet of Putin right and somebody if
you just look back at everything in the
history of this country especially when
it comes to foreign policy in different
Wars the more that they seem to want to
stop you from even asking questions
about something especially when it's our
money that's getting spent the more
important that I think it is to ask
those questions because every issue is
more complicated when it when it comes
down to it I mean look America's been a
lot of Wars the UK has been shoulder to
shoulder with most of them right yeah
um and a lot of them haven't turned out
very well exactly exactly we've wasted a
lot of money some have been more
Justified than others you know sometimes
to me a war like World War II where you
have adult Hitler the Nazis trying to
take over the world there's a clear and
present threat to the world that has to
be resisted a war like the second Iraq
war not the first which was pretty clear
but the second one I always felt was
fought on a false pretext I campaigned
against it so these things are never
actually cleared up we found out a lot
more to your point about Iraq and Saddam
Hussein too late absolutely and just
just like in this case back then it was
almost a demand of patriotism that you
just blindly support that war even
though there were so many logical
objective reasons to have questions the
way that they countered them would you
say oh well you just you don't you
fundamentally agree with the principle
that helping zelenski and the ukrainians
defeat Vladimir Putin is important for
Global democracy and freedom I think
that we need to remember that a lot of
the people that call for these wars
aren't the ones that have to go fight
them and that the people that fight them
it's not a zero-sum game I mean my
husband served in Afghanistan and I had
to watch him go through a very difficult
time after the Afghan pull out
especially knowing what we all know that
all the objectives that they were saying
they were accomplishing when the
Afghanistan papers came out again that
wasn't really well my brother served in
Iraq and Afghanistan particularly with
Iraq he was very you know disheartened
really by the fact that these weapons of
mass destruction never turned up the
reason for the conflict didn't exist
right but do you think most Americans
fundam I mean I remember for example the
first Gulf War
is Saddam Hussein invades Kuwait it's
not a NATO member but the first reaction
of America the superpower of the world
was to go and kick him out and most
people I know particularly most
Republicans actually supported that
action it's the only difference now that
Putin has all these nuclear weapons and
people are genuinely concerned that he
might use them well I I think it's to
cats point and to your point I think
people now have the the memory is a lot
longer now and I think anytime someone's
in trouble the average American is let's
go let's go do it the problem is is that
once we run in and we then we start to
see all this money going over there and
we're having a lot probably the most the
biggest problems we've ever had in this
country in terms of crime we've had to
defund the police propaganda going on
this country we've got protests non-stop
uh we've got problems in our education
and again when we're seeing problems uh
like with the chemical spill in
Palestine Ohio we're just not seeing
anything from the federal government so
it's about like where are our priorities
lie and unfortunately you have to look
at Allah out of the corruption or
allegations of corruption with this
white house when it comes to Ukraine
when it comes to China when it comes to
dealings of Hunter Biden so a lot of
Americans are skeptical and we want to
know where the money's going the one
thing that I I'm a big fan over with you
guys is even if someone Miss spends a
hundred dollars you guys are all over
that no you guys don't play where in
America it seems a hundreds of billions
of dollars and we don't ask about it
until they're already out of office
whenever you've spent the money well we
also we also call out our political
leaders online now
extraordinary interview this week with
Congressman George Santos who's now
become a global figure for all the wrong
reasons cat because he is one of the
worst Liars I think I've ever
encountered in public life let's just
take a reminder of what he confessed to
me eventually in our interview on Monday
I've been a terrible liar I mean would
you be prepared to say that sure like I
said well I've been a terrible liar on
those subjects
I mean the brazenness of it cat yeah
this guy's serving in Congress yeah and
he yes I'm a terrible liar I lie all the
time about everything and then he got
fact checked on his answers to the live
charges I put to him a CNN fact checked
him I found out he told a new load of
Whoppers about the existing Whoppers
yeah I love that he specified it saying
yeah I'm a terrible liar you know on
those subjects and then you know a
million more in this interview it's like
you're a terrible liar but you just love
it I mean I I it's it's it's uniquely
interesting the fact that even after
he's been caught so many times he
doesn't have any interest in changing or
maybe he doesn't even have the ability
to maybe there's something deeply
fundamentally wrong with this person
that I don't fully understand where he
doesn't even consider whether that's
what he's about to say Cyrus it has to
be said he's looked at someone like
Donald Trump who plays pretty fancy
loose with the truth and barreled his
way to the White House and presidency
maybe he thinks we're in a post-truth
world it doesn't really matter uh you
know what president Trump did have some
Deeds to back up his stuff and a lot of
things that he was supposedly lying
about we've come to learn he wasn't he
was telling it like it is just we didn't
necessarily want to hear it at the time
but the thing with Santos is I think you
have to look at it as a severe
narcissism and severe arrogance to where
he will continue to lie because he
thinks he can outsmart Everyone by keep
going I don't you have become America's
stepfather but like what you did when
Kanye was on you did the world's longest
interview to come around and then again
you sat you took this young man sat him
down in the Woodshed yes and tried to
get him like listen you tried to help
him out and again the arrogance and I
think the fact that he thinks he's the
smartest guy in the room and as long as
he has that type of mentality we're
going to continue to see these lies
because he doesn't have the ability to
come forward with his stuff because he's
just this is who he is this is who this
person is and he's not going to change
well talking about um deluded
narcissists who have a problem with the
truth Megan and Harry the current Duke
and Duchess of Sussex obviously there
was this South part mockumentary about
which was hilarious it's all so
devastating let's take a little reminder
because it always makes me laugh
it has been several months now since our
beloved Queen has died our Canadians are
finding it hard to go on oh Canadians
that is except for our first Guest The
Prince and his wife
thanks for having us on the show
we want privacy
um what's extraordinary is the reaction
in the polling since this book spare
camera will spare me as I prefer to call
it um Prince Harry was like by 32 and
disliked by 42 of those polled giving
him a net approval rating of minus ten
yep a drop of three points Mega marker
was like by 27 of Americans are disliked
by 44 giving her a net rating of -17
which is a drop of Four Points too so
both their popularity falling even
further since the book was supposed to
restore their reputations that makes
perfect sense to me because it's always
been an ability to clown on them about
you say you want your privacy and yet
you're in front of any camera that will
look at you you're a hypocrite but the
book they were also denying other people
in their life that kind of privacy they
were exposing other people's secrets so
this thing that you claim has hurt you
so badly you are now not just doing to
yourself but doing to other people as
well with impunity yes yes should we
care anymore about these
but here's the thing the good news is is
that she should be happy she's winning
she's up seven points on her husband and
uh I'm not a conspiracy theorist but I
did say on the Greg Gutfeld show that he
did not write this book She Wrote This
Book he just sat in the room with that
uncomfortable look on his face that he
always has like he's sitting on a plate
of glass so and again here's the thing
Americans people around the world that
love accountability when you write a
book to smear other people the the
immediate reaction is you want to look
to what to see that's why everyone was
buying and then you realize what kind of
a person would do that to their family
what kind of a person would put things
out there that's really not for you to
say and so that's what the reaction is
and they're like wow this is he would do
this to his family who else would he do
yeah in the dramatic part I was spare
parts listen if you were spare parts you
never would have been allowed out of the
test tube
like veal in a little box and because
you got to keep yourself the skin fresh
in case they needed it but those type of
comments in the moment and you were the
you were come on you stood your ground
the entire time uh came back to bite
them to where now people are rejecting
them as they should and South Park my
dream is to be made fun of myself
because they can't laugh at them they've
been doing it at a high level for so
long yeah they are above cancel culture
yeah and uh every time they do something
I just get tears my eyes laughing South
Park you keep doing what I totally agree
it's just the sussexes can't laugh at
themselves so for them it's the ultimate
nightmare for me be a badger all they do
is cry cry complain and you know what we
all know they're crying in a way nicer
home than almost anybody is exactly
great to see you great to see I know
you're racing off to run the the gut
field show tonight in his absence while
the while the rats away the mice are
playing yes you're gonna stick around
and give me a reaction to Jake Paul
because you're a massive boxing fan
you'll take is he a real boxer is he
gonna win on something don't answer
let's hold that Kat thanks for joining
us thanks for having me thanks tonight
is a YouTube Superstar term prize
fighter who's about to take on a
professional boxer Tommy Fury first Jake
Paul gets in the ring with me for a
world exclusive video that's next
[Music]
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
foreign
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Feltz is
on talk TV every night of the week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talk TV every day from 4pm
[Music]
foreign
every little helps for God's sake is
nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy
speechwriters here but we do and I
promise you discuss the issues that
matter to you yes I'm back talk TV not
with Morgan just before him Monday to
Thursday at 7pm join me just do it well
that one too
[Music]
this is talk TV
well one's a professional boxer the
other is a YouTuber who's taken up
boxing but the stakes could hardly be
higher Jake Paul fights Tommy Fury in
Saudi Arabia on Sunday the winner take
is all about it's got the whole world
talking Tommy Fury is a pro from a
famous fighting family his brother is
Tyson of course
and Tyson says he'll leave him in the
desert if he doesn't win Jane Paul is
best known as a Disney actor certain
YouTube mega star and he started boxing
in 2018. I'll be joined exclusively by
Jake in another but first take a look at
this
Jake Paul hasn't fought a real boxer yet
it's the fight two years in the making
there is no way that this man could beat
me even if he had a hammer in both hands
Jake there's his career is over if Tommy
can't spot to Jake Paul I'll retire him
from boxing myself when I knock out Army
Fury people will have nothing left to
say
[Music]
I think we make a deal then if you win
I'll pay you double but if I win I take
everything that I'm paying you deal or
no deal and Jake Paul beats Tommy Fury
Tommy Fury don't deserve
[Music]
well I'm joined now from Saudi Arabia by
Jake Paul Jake how are you
I'm good man it's been a it's been a
long day
um good to good to speak to you I know I
seen you clown Tommy Fury so please go
easy on me bro please go easy I actually
while I was waiting to interview I
watched you guys doing a thing together
quite interesting the body language
because both of you have a lot to lose
on Sunday night don't you're both
unbeaten a lot of Pride at stake a lot
of Legacy at stake here how are you
feeling about that
I love it man I love big moments I love
the high stakes this is what I came into
this sport to do is to put on big
pay-per-views big events and I'm putting
it all on the line the bigger the risk
the bigger the reward
um and there's a lot like you said on
the line it's UK versus us it's the
furies versus the Pauls and I have to go
out there and prove that I could beat a
professional boxer because that's been
the number one criticism of my career so
far so I'm super excited for this I want
to go back to before you started boxing
briefly because I'm fascinated about you
and your brother I've got three sons in
their 20s all of whom have followed both
of you for many years and have wanted me
to interview you for many years actually
you were both 10 and 12 living in Ohio
your dad was in real estate your mum was
a nurse and you get given a video camera
and you guys start just mucking around
with a video camera could you have ever
imagined that within 15 years you would
become two of the biggest internet stars
in the world
definitely not my friend uh this whole
journey has been absolutely surreal to
me it still doesn't make any sense I
feel like I'm living in a dream on a
day-to-day basis but we just have these
imaginations and are super creative and
we're willing to put in the work to
achieve our dreams and to achieve our
goals but that's part of my inspiration
of what drives me every single day is to
prove to other 10 and 12 year olds out
there that you know if you start
something if you create a hobby for
yourself if you work hard you can come
from a small town like me and and uh you
you can really make big things happen in
life did you have a a dream you guys
when you were young about how this might
play out or did you just think you know
what we're just going to go for it
because I've seen you talk about you've
got to take risks right you just have to
go for stuff and then stuff happens so
has this all been almost an accidental
journey to where you've got to or did
you have a game plan
yeah look at first there was sort of a
whirlwind and we were just taking it day
by day video by video but when we
started to make serious money when we
were 16 17 years old we realized that
this could be a legitimate business and
so we had uh you know we had two options
we stay in Ohio and keep making these
videos or do we move to Los Angeles and
go for it and try to become actors get
more involved in business collaborate
with the other big YouTubers and viners
at the time and the choice we made was
go to La and our parents supported us in
that decision and there we were you know
months later 17 and 19 years old in Los
Angeles I didn't know what a manager was
I didn't know what an agent was I didn't
even know what a lawyer did I had no
idea what I was getting myself into but
just showed up every single day and went
on tons and tons of auditions and kept
on making videos and before you know it
I booked a role on Disney Channel and
the videos kept going viral and one
thing led to another how much money have
you made
a lot a lot I don't I don't know it gets
to a point where you make so much that
you don't even count it anymore
um
so yeah I don't really know you don't
know how much money you've made I find
that hard to believe Jake you strike me
as somebody who knows exactly how much
money you've made
I I promise you Pierce Morgan I have I
have no idea I make money lump sums
residuals Investments Equity exits of
companies
um so the the net worth is always going
up and down but you know even moving
with the markets and such but
um I mean it when I say like I I you
stop paying attention at some point and
to me you know the money is great but I
I really love boxing and this is what I
was put on Earth to do and when I first
started out I wasn't getting paid like I
am getting paid now to box all these
guys
you know this is this is as of two three
years ago where the the Forbes list and
all this stuff started coming in from
this sport so
um I would be doing this regardless of
of the money I I I believe you but I
also know that you've you and your
brother are both exhibited a rare talent
for making a ton of cash and you are
influencers first I guess was what made
you what you were you're now a
professional boxer
there seemed to be a moment where you
were making all the money from the
YouTube stuff but it wasn't enough that
for you mentally you wanted to push
yourself in a different way and boxing
gave you that Escape Route perhaps from
the kind of Road you were going on what
was it about boxing that you think
really ignited that fire inside you
yeah look it was the routine the the
discipline
um the passion the challenge I wasn't
challenged anymore in YouTube I set a
goal to become the biggest daily vlogger
on YouTube I accomplished that goal I
was getting 15 million views a day and I
was tired of it I wasn't creatively
expressing myself properly I wanted to
move on to the next thing YouTube was
Banning everyone off their platform if
you swear and all types of crazy new
rules and limitations and I saw this I
saw that as a dead end and during that
time I I stumbled across boxing and it
took me back to my roots people forget
that I was a state wrestler a state
lacrosse player State football player
and so I really got back to my first
Dream which was to to be a professional
athlete
um and everything clicked when I got
into that boxing gym and I finally felt
at home and I was able to
mature through that process and figure
out who I truly was as a man so I needed
boxing
um and it sounds like the typical boxing
story but that's why there's so many
movies about it man because you hear it
time and time again and
um
the boxing the the boxing uh world and
all of that saved me for sure it's the
difference between your previous life
and this one that when you were a
YouTube influencer and that was how you
made your money and your Fame that a lot
of it could be very trivial you were
known for pranks you were known for
taking very little very seriously but
they're a very thing few things in life
more serious than getting into a ring to
fight another professional boxer where
actually your life could be at stake it
they couldn't be really two more
different things
no it's facts man and
um we we don't take that lightly you
know and I I know how serious of a sport
this is I know it's the hardest sport in
the world it's the hardest thing I've
ever done but something about that makes
me rise to the occasion and like you
said they're they're really Polar
Opposites you know waking up as a
YouTuber every day just wake up and do
whatever it is that you're gonna do come
up with an idea this is like a set
regimen with the team day in and day out
it's it's very professional very
difficult
um but man I'm just obsessed with it
you've called out a lot of famous
fighters from Conor McGregor
to others
um why do you do that and is it just to
provoke them do you want to be in that
orbit is it to get clicks is it to get
money what is it
no man it's it's because I really want
to fight them and that's what I've
proven when I first called these people
out everyone thought I was crazy I'm
definitely in a slightly crazy a little
bit but they didn't think that was
actually possible for these fights to
happen uh and then in less than three
years I've taken on some of the biggest
names in the sport some Combat Sports
Legends
um and so to me I always saw the vision
I always saw the game plan I always knew
what I was capable of and I think at
some points I was biting off more than I
could chew with calling out these guys
but my skill has quickly caught up to
um to be able to actually go in there
and beat some of these guys and I think
it's to a point now where when I called
out Conor McGregor everyone thought I
was crazy and now I guarantee you he
won't ever box me because I would beat
him and he knows that if I could be
Anderson Silva who's bigger stronger
faster better Striker than a smaller guy
and Conor McGregor is not going to want
to fight me
let me ask you about the fight on on
Sunday you're up against a guy like I
said he's unbeat there's a lot a lot of
stake here it's a proper fight now I
mean all the criticism you've taken that
you haven't had a proper fight against a
a sort of lifelong professional boxer
that criticism ends on Sunday night do
you have any doubt I hear you guys have
agreed now whoever wins takes all the
money and that's a lot of money nearly
10 million dollars have you got any
doubt in your head right now that you
will win and that you may win by
knockout
no I don't I'm confident in my
preparation you know
um Anything could happen in a boxing
match but you work to make those things
not happen
um and he just doesn't have the power
the capabilities to to do anything to be
able to defeat me and that's why I'm
willing to put my money where my mouth
is because talk is cheap and and that's
why I'm putting it on the line in Sunday
night you're going to see me knock this
guy out be there pay-per-view pull up
Piers Morgan thank you bro for having me
final question
would you ever fight your brother
I don't know I it depends what day you
ask me but
I don't know if it'll ever happen man we
could fantasize about it uh but who
would win who knows I think it could be
really interesting I would win I would
win and that's
that's the tough part is if he's okay
with being the older brother that loses
then I would do the fight but I just
don't know if he's going to be okay you
know this is how my younger brothers
talk about me
and I still beat them at arm wrestling
well
um
good for you pierce
actually the one thing I was going to
mention to you I know you're the king of
the internet and you've got 20 million
followers on Instagram but I just
checked on Twitter to see how you're
doing on that you only have four and a
half million followers on Twitter I've
got 8.4 million what does that make me
then
your your world famous Pierce and I
think I think you need to protag me like
you gotta tweet me tag me bro I need
some help there on Twitter
you know what Jake because I like you
because you give me an uncensored
interview I'm actually going to help you
out and get your following up a bit I'm
worried about you languishing down in
the formulas you know you need to get
that number up thank you bro hey good
luck on somebody follow me on Twitter at
Jake Paul Jake Paul the five million on
Twitter thank you he needs it he needs
help to get anywhere near me my friend
Cristiano Ronaldo is out in Saudi do you
think he's going to come to the fire
that's what the rumors are saying man
and
um I think Tommy's going to be his
masseuse after this like you said
Ronaldo
for having I think one of the greatest
work ethics of any athlete that's ever
played any sport at all do you look at
someone like him and see a role model
but
does he have the greatest masseuse Tommy
Fury Fury
I would actually stop this game up in
that category I would pay good money to
see Tommy be your message Hey Jake thank
you very much for your time I appreciate
it thank you thank you guys all the best
well a quick update uh to that uh end of
that conversation Cristiano Ronaldo has
just told me he's going to the fight on
Sunday and he thinks he's going to be a
great fight which many people do so
there we are uh you can listen to the
Jake Paul and Tommy Fury fight live and
for free this Sunday on talksport you
download the app you listen on dab or
you go to talksport.com
so who's gonna win well Champion
wrestler fox star Tyrus has some
thoughts strong thoughts and he'll give
them to me after the break
foreign
[Music]
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember it or thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Felts is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
every little helps for God's sake is
nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy speech
writers here but we do and I promise you
discuss the issues that matter to you
yes I'm back talk TV not with Morgan
just before him Monday to Thursday at
7pm join me just do it well that one too
[Music]
thank you
coming up on the talk the government
will assess thousands of Asylum claims
with a form instead of face-to-face
interviews the queen consort appears to
criticize the rewrites made to roll
Dahl's books and to stop another slap at
the Oscars organizers have assembled a
crisis team Yes you heard that correctly
we're discussing all of that at nine
o'clock
foreign
you've been a champion yes in the ring
what do you make of Jake Paul it seems
to me very Charming very switched on him
and his brother great marketers great
YouTube Sensations it's been amazing
American story a few kids from Ohio who
had a dream and like I said you cannot
not not like the guy and I applaud him
for for what he's done as a true boxing
fan uh I was not I don't I never put too
much weight in my opinion into the
celebrity boxing stuff or or fighting
guys from UFC who were past their prime
or whatever but he was able to uh cut
out something to where it was rivaling
boxing in the tennis people were tuning
in people were stopping to see him fight
and what they wanted to see was they
wanted to see one of their all-time
favorites one get a little shine again
and two knock him out and he has been
unable to do that uh the Silva fight I
thought was probably his toughest
Challenge and uh who's gonna win on
Sunday
well here's the deal in my opinion Paul
has nothing to lose he's making a huge
jump he's going to go from fighting guys
who boxing with something they picked up
like him to an actual boxer who's been
boxing since he was 13. and the pressure
is all on Fury one your big brother is
quite possibly one of the greatest
fighters of all time cerebrally and now
he decided to start using power God
helped the other heavyweights so the
pressure is all on Fury and Fury's last
fight he won every round he dominated
and he knocked a guy out who doesn't get
knocked out so and he's a very good
counter puncher so Paul started late I
commend his heart I I think he has shown
he loves the sport of boxing he was
offered a championship he didn't refuse
it he refused it I thought that was a
tremendous and shows who he is as a
person but he's about to make a huge
plunge and again we were talking the
back Sylvester Stallone had a great
thing where all the boxing and all the
training he was doing when he did a he
sparred with Roberto Duran one round and
he felt what it was like to be in there
with amateur muscle memory and uh muscle
memory in boxing is key that's why I
spent a morning watching Manny Pacquiao
at his peak in a gym in L.A but I know
you've been as well and it was so fast
so ferocious so powerful and the
watching it at Close Quarters it was
actually terrifying and he wasn't even
at the weight level these guys are at
right no he fights at 154 so when you
look at you look at can he eventually
get to a point remember he gets 20 21
fights under his belt of fighting other
boxers can he give Jamel Charro a run
for his money and I think that's most
people would say no not a chance in hell
but uh is it good for the sport of
boxing that you have these YouTubers I
say yes because they're still trying to
box and then when you watch Boxing at
the highest level you really have a
greater appreciation for it again I'm
not throwing any shade at Jake I think
what he's doing uh he's doing The
Honorable thing and now he's got to put
up or shut up because here's the deal if
Fury doesn't knock him out in three
rounds pounds I think he won yeah
because again uh and if the thing about
him that I like is that his his doesn't
really have the the shocking power but
he kind of wears guys down who would win
if he did fight his brother
I think the reason why his brothers
hopped into the wrestling world is
because the younger brother's a better
fight so
so but for older older brothers
everywhere it'd be a cold day in hell
for many of mine the last Brothers I
asked were the clip the Klitschko
brothers yeah and they never fought I
interviewed them in Ukraine their mother
would never let them do it but I said
who would win in Vitale who actually
never got knocked down in his entire
career he said well he said my brother
would be only because he's a lot younger
and still in the game in terms of
Fitness he said Boris but but I think at
that Peak I'm not I think entirely he
was a bad cut away from beating lennis
Lewis yeah let's not forget that yeah
it's a great fit it's going to be a
great fight it's good for boxing Fury
probably can't sleep he's got the
pressure of his brother he's got the
pressure of the boxing world and and
Jake Paul's playing with house money so
again great to see you I would pick Fury
but I I would not count out it's going
to be a great fight great to see you
thank you always a pleasure being on it
just want to end with a sad note uh and
John Monson in my opinion the greatest
football commentator there's ever been
uh died today he was known as motty I
met him a few times he was an absolute
genius in front of a broke casting
microphone and I want to display this
show up with a bit of John Madson
actually I think we might be shaken off
the German bench get up and protest at
Gasco in his last challenge
he has actually gascoigne got a yellow
car now oh dear
oh dearly
he's going to be out of the final
if england get
John Watson he was there for all the
greatest moments he was the greatest of
the commentators sad news that's it from
us tonight
Keep It Uncensored good night
[Music]
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
foreign
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Felts is
on talk TV every night of the week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it